police are still investigating tonight
after they say A man was shot and killed
at a home here off badura Avenue right
near Jones and the U.S 95. officers say
they got reports of a shooting just
after noon today and found a Hispanic
man in his 40s with a gunshot wound who
died here on scene Metro says the people
who own the home are getting ready to
sell it and the victim was a relative of
the owner here working when this
happened police are still searching for
a suspect but say this is an isolated
situation based information I had this
is an isolated incident it appears to be
something connected within this family
that owns the residence and who's doing
work on the residence
police say they are also trying to
determine whether the shooting happened
inside or outside this home and who was
here when it occurred now of course
officers are as I said still searching
for the suspect connected to this and
they are asking anyone with any
information to contact Metro Police or
Crime Stoppers to remain anonymous at
702-385-5555 reporting in the West
Valley tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now